la crevette calédonienne mets de choix
pour le japon plus de 600 tonnes de ces
crustacés s'envolent chaque année vers
le marché très exigeant de tokyo qui
sont premiers acheteurs
un gage de qualité qui permettent aux
fermes calédonienne d'envisager le
doublement de leur production dans les
cinq ans l'importateur exclusif de la
crevette calédoniennes c'est lui qui me
rico araya est le président de goda qu
un homme d'affaires avisé mais aussi un
esthète qui parcourt depuis 35 ans le
monde à la recherche des meilleurs
fruits de mers de la planète
en peu de temps il a réussi à poser la
crevette calédonienne congelés sur un
marché nippon pourtant très exigeant où
la compétition est impitoyable face
joaquin caton ce type de produit il
faute au départ un projet de travail à
très long terme et une stratégie du
marketing adaptées aux exigences de
qualité commence avec de toutes petites
quantités pour faire connaître la valeur
du produit est ensuite développer le
marché
kate a dit ceci étant tout cela a été
rendu possible grâce à une coopération
exemplaire avec la sopac qu'elle su
fédérer l'ensemble des aquaculteurs
calédonien quelle condition
indispensable au succès du projet pour
satisfaire ses exigences culinaires très
élevé kimiko haweij a ouvert il ya un an
son propre restaurant au coeur du tôkyô
chic à ginza désormais classé en tête
des restaurants du canton sur internet
l'établissement propose jusqu'à 12
recettes mettant en valeur la crevette
calédonienne à crustacés dont les
qualités gustatives sont
particulièrement apprécié des gourmets
nippon